cbs news senior national security
contributor michael morell was acting
and deputy director of the cia he joins
us from washington this morning michael
good morning good morning jeff
so a hydrogen bomb as has been noted is
much more dangerous
much more powerful first of all do you
believe it was a hydrogen bomb and if it
is should we be surprised
jeff
this was about 10 times stronger than
the previous tests
hydrogen bombs are
typically 10 to 100 times stronger than
atomic bomb so it's at the lower end
our intelligence community will be able
to determine whether it was a hydrogen
bomb probably too early though to to say
with certainty
would you be surprised if it is
no jeff i'm not at all um the u.s
intelligence community has been all over
this program for the last 25 years
the u.s intelligence community
discovered it in the early 1990s
that we've been focused on it since
we've we've predicted accurately how it
would evolve and why kim jong-un wanted
to do this so there isn't anything that
we've seen in the last i'd say five
years that has been a surprise it's all
been predictable we saw south korea with
a show of force right after and now
there's word from south korea that north
korea may have an icbm launch planned as
well how concerning is this escalation
of tension in the region right now
dana one of the things to remember is
that most wars
don't start with intent most wars start
because
people stumble into them mistakes are
made it's the way world war one started
so rising tension
of the kind we've seen in the korean
peninsula for the last six months is is
deeply concerning from from that respect
mike we heard defense secretary mattis
talking about military options president
trump tweeted about economic
consequences for countries that trade
with north korea and suggested that
south korea is appeasing the north is
that a right approach
vlad i think
that the best approach here is
is the right words and the right actions
the right words are sober right it's
it's keeping all options open it's that
we will defend our allies at all costs
we will protect ourselves this is the
way this is exactly what jim mattis said
those are the right words um we
shouldn't be threatening the north in
terms of actions we should be ramping up
the sanctions we should be building our
missile defense and that of south korea
and japan
and we should make that known we should
conduct more missile defense tests um
that's what we should be doing right now
but michael let me just if the approach
has been sober for years and years and
they've continued this this lurch
towards the nuclear weapon what what
prevents them from getting it are you
just to assume that it's going to happen
jeff jeff i think at the end of the day
we face two choices
one is a military attack with with
devastating consequences and no
guarantee of success and the other is
acceptance of where they are and where
they're going with containment and
deterrence i think the latter makes the
most sense i think that's where we'll
end up
michael morell thank you very much as
always sir
welcome